STEVE?
STEVE: THAT’S GREAT, THANKS,
JILLIAN.
THE VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
IS GOING TO FINALLY SEE THE
BORDER CRISIS FIRSTHAND TOMORROW
THREE MONTHS AFTER BEING TAPPED
TO LEAD THE ADMINISTRATION’S
RESPONSE.
HARRIS WILL HEAD TO EL PASO,
TEXAS ALONG WITH HOMELAND
SECURITY CHIEF HE WILL ALEJANDRO
MAYORKAS.
CRITICS ARE QUESTIONING THE
TIMING WITH FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP ALREADY ANNOUNCED IS HE
GOING TO VISIT THE BORDER NEXT
WEEK.
TEXAS CONGRESSMAN TONY GONZALES
FROM THE EL PASO AREA JOINS US
LIVE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SIR.
>> GOOD MORNING, STEVE.
STEVE: GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
YOU ARE THE CONGRESSMAN FOR THAT
REGION.
ALSO, BUT YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
BE THERE YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE
THERE TO SHOW HER WHAT SHE IS
MISSING.
BUT, INSTEAD, SHE IS PROBABLY
GOING TO BE WELCOMED BY VERONICA
ESCOBAR, A DEMOCRAT UNLIKE HENRY
CUELLAR WHO HAS BEEN VERY
CRITICAL OF THE ADMINISTRATION,
SHE HAS BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, I’M HEARING
THE VICE PRESIDENT ISN’T GOING
TO BE ON THE GROUND VERY LONG.
ONLY A FEW HOURS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THE FLIGHT
TO EL PASO IS GOING TO BE LONGER
THAN THE TIME THAT SHE IS GOING
TO BE ON THE GROUND.
AND THAT’S REALLY YOU HAVE THE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I AM EXCITED THAT
SHE IS AT LEAST SHOWING UP.
KEVIN McCARTHY AND A BUNCH OF
US VISITED BACK IN MARCH.
STEVE SCALISE HAS DONE THE SAME.
YOU KNOW, LEADERSHIP IS ABOUT
SHOWING UP.
BUT REALLY IT’S NOW, WHAT, YOU
KNOW, WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO SEE
HOPEFULLY IS NOT JUST A PHOTO
OP., THEY ARE GOING TO HEAR THAT
FENTANYL IS COMING OVER AT
RECORD NUMBERS.
YOU KNOW, UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN
OVER 80,000 UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN, OVER 800,000 MIGRANTS.
SO, AND NOW IT’S THE NOW WHAT
FACTOR.
STEVE: SURE.
FOR ENOUGH TO FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ADMIT OKAY SHE
IS GOING TO GO DOWN AND SEE THE
CRISIS WITH HER OWN TWO EYES.
WAIT A MINUTE THERE IS A CRISIS?
THEY HAVE TRIED TO PRETEND THIS
IS NOT A BIG PROBLEM.
MAYORKAS HAS SAID THE STRATEGY
IS, WOULDING THAT PUZZLES
EVERYBODY.
WHY EL PASO?
WE HEARD IN A COUPLE OF
SOUNDBITES A LITTLE WHILE AGO,
IF SHE REALLY WANTED TO SEE IT
GO TO DONNA, TEXAS, REFER KIDS
IN CAGES INSTEAD SHE IS GOING TO
EL PASO.
WHAT IS SHE GOING TO SEE THERE.
>> YOU REALLY CAN’T BE A BORDER
SECURITY EXPERT IF YOU ARE ON
THE GROUND FOR TWO HOURS.
YOU KNOW, HAVE YOU GOT TO PUT
SOME EFFORT INTO THIS.
AND THE REALITY IS EL PASO, THE
EL PASO SECTOR IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN RIO GRAND VALLEY OR DEL RIO
OR THE BIG BEND SECTOR OR THE
LAREDO SECTOR, THEY ALL ARE
DIFFERENT.
IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND THIS
CRISIS, YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT ALL PARTS OF THE BORDER ARE
DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW, HER SHOWING UP AND
TAKING A PHOTO OP., GETTING BACK
ON A PLANE AS FAST AS SHE CAN
IT’S DISRESPECTFUL AS WELL.
BUT, WHAT I’M REALLY WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IS THIS ADMINISTRATION
HAS TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
TITLE 42 IF THEY DO AWAY WITH
TITLE 42, AS BAD AS THINGS ARE
NOW, YOU ARE GOING TO SEE THEM
GET WORSE.
STEVE: SOUNDS LIKE THEY ARE
GOING TO.
TITLE 42 ALLOWED BORDER PATROL
PEOPLE AT THE BORDER STOP THERE
IS A PANDEMIC, YOU HAVE GOT TO
GO BACK TO MEXICO.
SOUNDS LIKE BECAUSE THE ACLU IS
CHALLENGING THEM IN COURT THEY
ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
QUIETLY GET RID OF IT SO THEY DO
NOT HAVE TO DEFEND THE DONALD
TRUMP POLICIES WHICH THEY DID
NOT WANT TO DO.
SPEAKING OF DONALD TRUMP,
CONGRESSMAN, YOU KNOW,
100 PERCENT IS TRUE.
THE REASON SHE IS GOING
TOMORROW, IS BECAUSE DONALD
TRUMP ANNOUNCED HE WAS GOING TO
GO DOWN TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER
WITH GREG ABBOTT NEXT WEEK.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
I MEAN, WE HAVE PUT WILL
POLITICAL PRESSURE ON HER FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS AND MONTHS TO
SHOW UP.
YOU KNOW, THANKFULLY, FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IS COMING
DOWN AND ALL OF A SUDDEN, YOU
KNOW, YOU PUT THEIR HEAD IN A
POLITICAL VICE AND THEN THEY
START MOVING.
BUT, YOU KNOW, LIKE I SAID, I’M
GLAD SHE IS AT LEAST SHOWING UP.
NOW WHAT?
WE NEED ACTIONS.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT.
TONY GONZALES, JOINING US TODAY
FROM THE D.C. AREA.
HE HAS GOT SOME VOTES.
THAT’S WHY HE IS NOT GOING TO BE